[موسيقى]
بصفتها ناشطة في مجال الحفاظ على البيئة ، مارومو نيني لديها
شغف بالحيوانات
لأكثر من عقد من الزمان عملت
في
منظمة الحياة البرية
الجنوب أفريقية غير الهادفة للربح مارومو تكرس وقتها لحماية
بعض الأنواع الأكثر قيمة
في إفريقيا في
حديقة الفلسفة أقدم حياة برية محمية
لكونك من دعاة الحفاظ على البيئة ، يجب أن
تتحلى بالصبر
لأنك تعلم أن مطاردة المال
هنا يتعين علينا القيام بذلك بدافع الحب
للحيوانات ،
فأنا نحب كلاب الحائط
لأنها السبب
في أنني مكثت هنا في المرة الأولى
التي تلقيت فيها  فرصة لرصدهم
في البداية لم أفهم لماذا يتعين
علينا مراقبة الكلاب
ثم تعلمت سلوكهم هيكلهم
الاجتماعي بالطريقة التي يصطادون بها ثم وقعت
في حبهم وحقيقة أنهم
معرضون للخطر ،
نعم هذا يجعل  أريد أن أحميهم
أكثر ، فالكلب البري الأفريقي الذي يُطلق عليه أحيانًا اسم
الذئب الملون هو أحد
الأنواع المهددة بالانقراض ويقدر قانون الحياة البرية
أنه لم يتبق سوى 6600
في البرية
وأقل من 550 شخصًا يعيشون في جنوب إفريقيا
يتتبع مارومو الكلاب
على مدار الساعة وهو أمر أساسي لحماية
السكان
[الموسيقى]
وظيفتي هي مراقبة أبوابهم
والتأكد من بقائهم
داخل الحديقة ثم
إذا  لقد خرجوا أيضًا ، انضممت إلى الفريق
لإحضارهم نوعًا ما في marubo وجعلها
منزلها في الأدغال
تعيش جنبًا إلى جنب مع الكلب البري
الذي تعتني به بعد أن تغمر
نفسها في بيئتها وهي تتعرف على
تحركاتهم وسلوكياتهم
مما يسمح لإدارة المنظمة
يجب على الموظفين اتخاذ قرارات أفضل بشأن
رعايتهم ،
لذا فإن ما أفعله هو الاستيقاظ في الصباح الباكر
حتى أجدهم وهم لا يزالون
مستريحين عندما أستيقظ ،
فأنا هناك لمعرفة الطريقة التي يذهبون بها ،
وأحتاج إلى متابعتهم
حتى  إذا لم أرهم
[موسيقى]
، فلديهم لغتهم الخاصة
وعندما يغذونهم مثل
تويتر أشعر وكأنني واحد من هؤلاء الأشخاص الآن.